c'est par une minute de silence plein de
respect et d'émotion que toutes les
rencontres sportives ont débuté ce
week-end pour rendre hommage aux
victimes de l'attentât perpétré dans les
locaux du journal charlie hebdo est à
montrouge cette semaine évidemment
toutes nos pensées vont aux proches des
victimes
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport on passe tout de suite au sommaire
de cette édition du 12 janvier désigné
monteyne n'ont pas tremblé face aux
deuxièmes villemomble montigny s'est
imposé pour le compte de la 11ème
journée de nationale 2 un succès qui
permet de croire à la montée en fin de
saison ce week-end le comité
départemental de cyclisme des yvelines
mettait à l'honneur ses meilleurs jeunes
coureurs sur 2014 occasion de faire un
zoom sur la relève et débuter un projet
à moyen terme sur la piste
décryptage des ambitions dans cette
émission du sky rugby en promotion
d'honneur toujours troisième à l'aube de
la phase retour mais qui s'est inclinée
ce week-end à reims est évidemment en
fin d'émission l'essentiel des résultats
du week-end mais tout d'abord place au
cyclisme
je le disais dans les titres de ce sept
huit sports ce week-end le comité
départemental de cyclisme des yvelines
mettait à l'honneur ses meilleurs jeunes
coureurs de 2014 occasion de faire un
focus sur la relève yvelinoise et
débuter un projet à moyen terme voire à
long terme sur la piste et notamment sur
le vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images pour certains ils effectuent
leurs tout premiers tours de roue sur
une piste mais ils sont déjà très à
l'aise sur l'anneau du vélodrome après
seulement une saison sur le vélo et une
8e place en coupe de france
alix durant a encore besoin de gagner en
explosivité
mais sa polyvalence lui permet d'être à
l'aise sur tous les terrains
cette année ça a été un bon début de
saison j'ai gagné ma première course
cette première course et puis après j'ai
fait plusieurs sélections en
ile-de-france sur la coupe de france
donc ça s'est très bien passé
on dit souvent que pour une première
année c'est un bon début donc j'espère
progresser par la suite et réussir à
faire quand des choses plus grandes
quatre victoires en 2014 meilleur
grimpeur du tour de l'île de france
cadets et champion des yvelines
michael rambo et l'espoir du cyclisme
yvelinois masculin mais le jeune
cycliste reste les pieds sur terre
c'est trop tôt pour y penser j'aimerais
bien c'est sûr mais sait on peut pas
trop savoir à l'avancé encore beaucoup
de chemin à faire
avec l'implantation du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
les jeunes cyclistes bénéficient
désormais d'un outil de travail
exceptionnel
à long terme les yvelines veulent
devenir une référence dans l'information
sur piste notre rôle au niveau du comité
départemental c'est de leur permettre de
venir découvrir de venir se
perfectionner progressé de façon à
participer à des compétitions de niveau
régional pour certains des compétitions
de niveau national et surtout de
bénéficier d'un encadrement
professionnel
le but du projet constitué un groupe
homogène qui se spécialisera à moyen
terme sur la piste et cela va commencer
par des cessions sur le vélodrome
nationale pour préparer l'inter-région
kb en mai prochain sur l'anneau saint
quentinois
et place au rugby
donc est ce week-end je le disais le sky
rugby a perdu sur la pelouse du stade de
reims pourtant huitième au classement et
le sky rugby qui était dans le top 4 10
à 7
mais le club saint quentinois reste
quand même dans la course pour la montée
analyse de ce sprint final avec
l'entraîneur guillaume payen dans soir
guillaume monchaux merci d'être là alors
on va tout d'abord un débrief et ce
match de ce week-end de reprise premier
match de 2015 une défaite qui vous
laisse un goût amer
clairement oui rassam leurs prix que
nous en 2015
on arrive sur tout finit bien 2014
donc on est sur une bonne dynamique ah
les vacances nous ont fait pas du bien
sur ce coup là on n'est pas loin du
compte que la main au final si on
regarde juste scénario de match on est
sur la ligne d'en-but a pilonné à la fin
et si on marque
il ya une victoire qui souffrait pas de
contestation on va dire maintenant sur
l'ensemble du match on les joueurs les
premiers étaient été déçus on n'a pas
réussi à mettre assez de jeu on a fait
trop de fautes on est trop de fautes
sifflées contre nous et donc on est déçu
vraiment d'autant plus que l'objectif on
s'est rendu compte en vue des matches de
2014 que la première place était pas
accessible
par contre la deuxième place clairement
notre charge conseil me entre nous on va
voir les classements pour arriver à ça
les sports les scores d'hier mais avant
de glisser au massif central inquiet qui
est leader de cette poule
et c'est vrai qu'il semble ainsi contre
à la bhl inaccessible moment si bas
qu'ils gagnaient avec le bonus puis
redoutable on voit le classement prend
de l'avancé sur nous alors que
clairement c'est bah c'est notre point
rouge insert c'est le match la défaite à
domicile qu'on a lyon on prend à partie
de saison moment aussi qui nous fait des
regrets c'est le seul match qui vous
fait des regrets agents allemands hier
maintenant là celui d'hier en plus mais
la saison dans le monde en six 6 le
nôtre challenge il est avec eux c'est à
dire que nous sommes arrivés ici ont
fini deuxièmes on fait une bonne saison
si on finit 3e ont fait de moi et c'est
bon ça
c'est très clair justement sur ce match
de ce week-end pour revenir dessus une
dernière fois est-ce que c'est pas quand
même un style de match un type de match
que nous ne devait pas perdre justement
en vue de vos ambitions barre après
effectivement faut regarder le
classement on a une poule assez
particulière où même les équipes du bas
de classement arrive à attraper les
équipes du haut de classement
donc c'est assez particulier comme comme
poule maintenant voilà on a une équipe
de reims qui on avait gagné à l'aller
largement certes chez nous certains on
est en déplacement à l'extérieur voilà
mais franchement voilà on est très déçus
parce que peut-être que là on se rentre
en question est quand même réagir ce
week end chez nous contre bologne a pas
de raison on fait confiance aux joueurs
pour ça parce que parce que simplement
là c'est la cerise sur le gros de ces
leçons d'hier on a par attac et 2015
comme on aurait souhaité à charge pour
nous nous avons rattrapé directement et
d'enchaîner puisque on a quatre matches
de suite encore à faire donc on a un
gros rythme gros rythme cinq matchs de
suite c'est au mois de janvier en plus
donc c'est dur pour les corps c'est
clair mais alors justement avec ce après
cette défaite votre objectif c'est quoi
c'est de conforter sa troisième place on
l'a vu s'afficher à l'écran le
classement vous avez cinq points de
retard derrière moment aussi où essayer
d'aller rechercher cette deuxième place
comme au lycée d'aller chercher sa
deuxième place sincère que le week-end
prochain aux jo bonneuil
objectif revenir avec 5 points t on à
l'entière francis de la poule bonus
offensif impératif chez nous d'autant
qu'on l'avait pris au match aller chez
eux
et puis la semaine d'après ben on va
moment ci comme ça au moins on saura
rapidement si on veut être 2e pour
agréer moment si ce n'est pas moi aussi
on sera pas deuxième qu'est ce qui fait
défaut un petit peu à votre équipe cette
saison même si l'on il ya quand même un
classement qui est toute somme correcte
cette troisième place mais n'a jamais eu
quatre victoires consécutives par
exemple même si vous avez les vous est
l'équipe qui a le plus de bonus offensif
par exemple il ya toujours ce petit
problème défensif
cette rigueur ouais bah justement
on a la meilleure attaque de la poule on
n'est même plus de tags de points que le
premier de la poule
donc c'est très bien parce qu'on a
beaucoup travaillé là dessus
maintenant on a resserré la vis pas ce
que m'ont donné il faut quand même
capable de laisser moins dé 100 comprend
- d'essaimer problème c'est qu'en même
temps on marque moins de points ainsi
donc donc faut réussir à trouver le bon
équilibre
et puis bah quand il a marqué autant de
points qu'on marque un début d'année
pour pouvoir pouvoir gagner à nouveau
quoi donc on n'est pas on n'est pas
inquiet on n'est pas inquiet on est déçu
vraiment d'hier m'ont n'est pas inquiet
du tout ce qui se passe et ensuite vous
allez juste voir ça comme il faut les
joueurs vu la réaction d'après match
on est sûr que demain soir entraînement
ils seront pris à fond pour pourra se
rattraper
on s'attrape tous ensemble de cet échec
d'hier et puis puis de repartir
directement par une belle victoire
contre bologne et puis après notre
challenge de la deuxième place après un
moment où justement bonneuil face à un
mal classé et un dernier de votre poule
où c'est l'occasion aussi de prendre un
autre bonus offensif et puis peut-être
grappillé petit à petit sur moment
entier avant cette france est ce duel et
ce face à face
c'est ça l'idée clairement on a laissé
hier on a pris un point de bonus
défensif mais on aurait dû prendre
quatre points voire 5 sur l'objectif
qu'on s'est fixé
on a laissé en route plus trop de place
pour finir deuxièmes plus falloir le
faire autant la deuxième c c'est
simplement les phases finales donc c'est
quelque chose qui est là bas pas connu
ces dernières saisons et qui nous motive
chaque jour pour travailler quoi très
bien merci beaucoup guillaume d'être
passés sur le 7-8 sport et donc coup
d'envoi à 15 heures ce dimanche
du coup des sky rugby face à bonneuil
on enchaîne avec le sport automobile
c'était l'un des plus grands pilotes
français symbole un peu de l'âge d'or du
sport automobile jean pierre beltoise
vous le savez est décédé lundi dernier
peu avant l'approché de la précédente
émission à l'âge de 77 ans il est l'un
des rares pilotes à avoir brillé sur
deux roues avant de passer sur 4 euros
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les yeux
match 86 grand prix de formule 1 huit
podiums dont le mythique succès à monaco
1972 sous une pluie battante pilote à
l'aise partout 11 fois champion de
france de moto 14 participations 24
heures du mans jean pierre beltoise aime
la compétition par dessus tout et les
qualités de trajectoire jean pierre a
été le premier qui a redonné un certain
lustre spa automobiles français et qui a
entraîné dans la foulée d'abord une
revalorisation du sport automobile qui
était un peu tombé en désuétude de en
france est une réussite qui inspire de
nombreux pilotes comme arnaud jabouille
ou encore prost après sa carrière il a
consacré la suite de sa vie à la
sécurité des pilotes
développe des stages de prévention
notamment au circuit qui portait son nom
à trappes avec sa méthode conduire juste
tu voulais ça m'intéresse pas du tout de
faire des circuits pour faire plaisir
ce qui m'intéressait de faire du cirque
et pour qu'un jour le gouvernement et
les responsables des boîtes 10
effectivement avec le système mis au
point par jean pierre beltoise et qu'on
dira gestes ont réduit de moitié ou des
deux tiers ou des trois cases accidents
de la route
très proche de son personnel ici à
trappes parce que la plupart des gens
qui ont collaboré avec lui
l'on fait et le font depuis quasiment
l'origine c'est-à-dire pour la majorité
collaborateurs c'est plus de 20 ans jean
pierre beltoise est décédé à l'âge de 77
ans après deux accidents
cardiovasculaires à dakar et pour le
compte de la 11ème journée de national
de montigny le bretonneux recevait ce
week-end le deuxième villemomble dans un
match qui ressemble à un petit peu à un
duel pour en tout cas un duel peut être
décisif pour une fin de monter une
montée pardon en fin de saison ça ira
mieux alors à l'endroit désigné montrent
elles n'ont pas tremblé au final
victoire d'un tout petit but résumé
réalisé avec patrick raguenaud en 2015
il faut croire que les entames de match
en mode diesel cela n'existe plus à
montils face aux deuxièmes villemomble
lésiné monteyne ne se laisse pas piéger
après un quart d'heure de jeu elle mène
de quatre buts 9 à 5
dans une première période très serré et
électrique les deux équipes se répondent
coup pour coup à la pause rien n'est
fait montini mène d'une longueur 13 à 12
on s'est fait peur quand il y avait
ex-aequo et on a su remonter au score
donc c'était pas mal et reprendre nos
esprits surtout écouté les consignes du
coach et pierre des joueuses en place et
on a fait le boulot derrière car
villemomble est une des deux seules
équipes à avoir fait chuter le leader
havrais cette saison les joueuses de
seine-saint-denis le prouve et
s'accroche au score mais les joueuses de
philippe l'étrange ne reproduisent pas
les erreurs commises à lisieux lors de
la 10e journée rigoureuse jusqu'au bout
elle s'impose finalement d'un petit but
24-23 grâce notamment à 8 banderille de
carole mittelheisser une victoire
précieuse face à un concurrent pour la
montée qui pourrait faire basculer leur
fin de saison
c'est tendu très serré on a réussi à
allez tous me robin on était devant tout
naturellement qu'on perde la cdpa russie
n'était pas mesrine est restée sereine
et propre pas trop de deux minutes
la montée on y pense un parce que je
pense qu on a fait pas mal d'erreurs
notamment sur deux matches perdus un
alizé l'autre à contre saint michel chez
nous et je pense que les matches retours
vont être très importants puisque la
phase retour commence maintenant et pour
débriefer ce match de cette 11e journée
l'entraîneur et la capitaine de l'as
montini emballe sont présents sur le
plateau du 7-8 sports philippe l'étrange
bonsoir
évidemment de gabriel parloir bonsoir si
abriel merci et d'être là tous les deux
alors j'imagine que c'est la
satisfaction qui domine après ce match
face à villemomble philippe bien sûr oui
on termine les matches aller en étant
deuxième en battant villemomble un
concurrent direct
donc c'est une belle satisfaction
surtout à ne rien lâcher la fin de match
était tendue dont 15 ont défendu comme
on le leur avait demandé ça c'est bien
vous auriez signé au début de saison
pour être à cette place après les
matches aller à gabriel oui c'est vrai
qu'on fait une bonne première partie de
championnat on n'a pas toujours excellé
mais on a souvent chercher les trois
points à l'arraché et au final notre
deuxième place je pense qu'on l'a mérité
voyez eu beaucoup de matches dans cette
première partie de saison où vous
démarriez un petit peu en mode diesel la
rencontre et puis comme vous le disiez
un gabriel bas il ya ces victoires un
petit peu à l'arraché d'un ou deux buts
mais sa passe est quand même et là il ya
c'est un petit peu changé on a
l'impression dans l'état d'esprit non je
ne sais pas si ça a changé il ya
beaucoup on a demandé ce week-end à ce
qu'elle soit guerrière pour ce match là
et surtout le match qui va arriver
contre entre le havre
tellement fait vraiment c'est aussi une
façon de marquer un peu votre road
territoire parce que là c'était un choc
entre deux équipes qui étaient sur le
podium donc vous marquez un petit peu
les esprits avec cette victoire face à
villemomble gabriel oui surtout qu'on
s'est donné les moyens
chose qu'on n'a pas forcément fait face
à des moins bien classés on s'est
vraiment donné les moyens et on allait
chercher la victoire qu'on avait
vraiment envie d'avoir avec avec la
forme justement par rapport à cette
victoire maintenant on peut on est
obligé de le dire la montée on y est on
en parle pour cette fin de saison pas
philippe on parle de plus en plus
maintenant il reste onze matches à
effectuer il est onze matches vont être
difficiles
en sachant qu'on se déplace chez tous
les les cadors donc ça va être compliqué
maintenant c'est pas irréalisable mais
j'espère à la fin des matches aller on
voit qu'on a cinq points d'avancé sur le
5e
donc il reste quatre équipes pour deux
places et dans les quatre équipes ya une
équipe certainement qui peuvent remonter
le havre donc ça peut être très
intéressant ça va être sûrement tendu
jusqu'au bout d'ailleurs en regardant un
petit peu le calendrier tout à l'heure
en préparant les missions il ya sûrement
un dernier match de la saison qui
pourrait être décisif c'est avidement
lors de la dernière journée gabriel ça
ça peut être le match de tous les deux
tout les extrêmement sas et jouera pas
là dessus parce que c'est un peu quitte
ou double quoique c'est des matches qui
sont assez tendus soit on soit on lâche
complètement prise et pied on donne tout
et puis on se transcende ou soir on joue
avec le frein à main
donc j'espère de ne pas connaître la
situation
une prise de conscience au sein du
groupe de l'équipe justement de voir qui
allait les victoires qui s'enchaînent et
puis qui a sept places au classement
oui et non enfin jusqu'à avant la trêve
de noël
on sentait que c'était c'était un peu
poussif et l'a dit le dernier match
avant la trêve a confirmé tout ça
puisque on allait perdre chez un mal
classé et je pense que ça nous a un
petit peu mis une claque et ça nous a ça
nous a réveillés
donc je pense qu'on va repartir de
l'avant et du bon pied
pour ses 11 matière il ya une joueuse
qui a un petit peu pris votre relève
parce qu'auparavant on avait un air
saison c'était un peu vous la meilleure
marqueuse de montigny même dans l'est au
niveau du championnat cette fois ci
c'est fanny jean baptiste qui a les
stats on aime bien les statistiques nous
les les journalistes plutôt intéressante
quatrième meilleure buteuse du
championnat et puis il ya encore eu pas
mal de buts ce week-end ça vous aime des
joueuses comme ça très en forme sur ce
bon tout le monde marque
contrairement à l'année dernière encore
là tout le monde m'a alors plus ou moins
de buts c'est sur mais bon on peut pas
se passer d'une famille shaw matisse ou
même d'une gabriel cas vous préférez
jouer un peu à l'aise pour cette année
donc à moins de ballon donc on ne peut
mieux cibler possibilité pas bon de
marquer des buts et c'est ce qui fait
peut-être un peu votre force par rapport
à la saison passée c'est que le danger
peut venir un petit peu plus de partout
par rapport aux autres saisons
c'est clairement ça donc c'est que si sa
pêche un petit peu à un endroit il y
aura toujours quelqu'un pour prendre la
relève derrière prochains matchs donc
face au havre déjà ça sera un premier un
premier signe pour cette fin de saison
philippe pas spécialement on va y aller
plus décontracté parce qu'on a gagné ce
week-end maintenant je pense ça va
déterminer le premier week-end si on
perd wav on aura quatre points de retard
sur le havre avec un goal avérage
particulier en défaveur donc je pense ça
sera difficile d'aller les récupérer
sauf si elle ses coûts maintenant si on
gagne tout restera à faire je crois que
le match très très important c'est qu'il
faut qu'on prépare ses mi février contre
val d'orge ou là c'est
ça va être un tronc l'un des tournants
très bien merci à tous les deux d'être
passé sur le site sport on va suivre
avec beaucoup d'attention cette fin de
saison qui promet d'être très palpitante
du côté de montigny on enchaîne avec les
résultats du week-end vous aviez
peut-être réserver votre place il y a
quelques jours ou quelques semaines pour
le combat pour la ceinture de l'union
européenne des super moyens c'est de la
boxe entre adil hamouma dit l'élan
courtois et l'espagnol mariano hilario
et bien un changement de programme il y
a quelques jours a dit l'amour m'a dit
nous a annoncé qu'il était souffrant et
donc le combat est reporté pour cause de
maladie ne sera donc pas présent sur le
ring ce samedi soir qu'on va repousser
au 14 mars prochain on voit quelques
images d'ailleurs daddy là en pleine
action lors de son combat pour la
ceinture de champion de france
il y a deux ans on enchaîne on continue
dans les résultats du week-end et pas de
résultats football ce week end justement
puisque à la suite de l'attentât à
charlie hebdo et le passage du plan
vigipirate au niveau attentats la ligue
de paris ile de france a décidé de
reporter toutes les rencontres du
week-end en rugby le chemin de croix
continue pour plaisir pour le compte de
la 11ème journée de fédérale 2 le prc
s'est lourdement incliné à domicile lors
du de cette dernière journée face aux
quatrièmes 90 53 à 5 les plaisirs wa
reste à une bien triste neuvième place
handball
on reste dans le handball deuxième phase
du championnat de france des moins de 18
ans qui a ouvert ses portes ce week-end
et cela très mal débuté pour la team 78
le joueur les joueurs d'alexandre
taillefer se sont lourdement inclinés à
créteil 53 à 32 ans basket et de trois
pour l'entente le chesnay-versailles les
féminines de l'ol cv ont glané leur
troisième victoire de la saison ce
samedi face à rezé 50 à 46 et cela sans
certaines choses un majeur toujours
blessé comme melanie b est pour le
compte de la 13e journée de nationale 2
évidemment et au classement vous allez
le voir une victoire qui permet de
conserver l'espoir la glacerie et
réguler un son toujours en tête et dans
la deuxième partie de tableau les
joueuses de vinko bardy qui gagne une
place et sont désormais
dixièmes avec 16 points le maintien est
donc toujours envisageable toujours
basket mais chez les hommes cette
fois-ci nationale 3 13e journée
également et zéro pointé ce week-end
trappe s'incline logiquement face à
poissy 69 à 74 et de son côté la pire
défense de la poule l'entente le
chesnay-versailles n'y arrive toujours
pas nouvelle défaite à ormes 68 à 64 et
au classement pas de grands changements
et gennevilliers poissy sont toujours co
leader en bas du tableau vous allez le
voir trappe reste 8e et le lcv 11e
derniers résultats c'est du volley-ball
12e journée de régionale une ce week-end
et montini n'a rien pu faire face au
leader cormeilles en parisis défaite
cinglante 3 sets à 0 malgré une première
manche assez accroché lésigny montain
sont désormais 8e
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 pour remercier
encore une fois de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain même lieu même
heure d'ici là excellente soirée sur tf1